... la sce reportage.
- Charger un peu moins
pour séduire plus d'abonnés
et encaisser des revenus
publicitaires : c'est le pari
que fait Netflix à comptere même
que Disney+ à partir du début
décembre.
BRUNO GUGLIELMINETTI,
spécialiste nouvelles technos
des budgets beaucoup plus serrés
au niveau du divertissement
et j'avoue que l'offre
publicitaire, qui va coûter
publicités, va probablement
avoir plus de succèsèsès
avec les temps économiques
qu'on connaît présentement.
- Le nouvel abonnement
de Netflix coûtera 6 $ par mois,
soit 4 $ de moins que le forfait
de base et 10 $ de moins
En échange, les clients verront
quatre à cinq minutes
de publicités à l'heure.
- Est-ce que les gens vont être
parce que ce n'est pas comme
si ça tosi ça tosi ça tombait d.
On connaît ça, de la publicité
entre... pendant les émissios. ,
c'est une adaptation à fairesi .
Mais reste que dans les deux
Netflix, si vous êtes prêts
à payer le plein prix, bien,
vous n'en aurez pas,
- Selon l'Observatoire
des techdes techdes techdes tec,
62 % des Québécois francophones
souscrivent actuellementt Amazoe
Video et Disney+, puis l'EXTRAd%
chacun, et le Club Illico
des ménages québécois abonnés.
Même si Netflix reste numéro un
son nombre d'abonnés chuter
pour la première fois au début
de l'année, avant cet été. Il cc
de nouvelles sources de reve
SYLVAIN LAFRANCE, directeur,
Pôle médias, HEC Montréal
en décembre, l'industrie ne va
pas imploser. Maispeu
comme toutes les nouveautés
comme ça qui arrivent sur
au début, on ne craint pas trop,
puis on  finalement
que c'est encore un nouveau
joueur qui vient chercher
fortement fragilisée.
CHRISTIA, directrice
princ., ICI TOU.TV et Jeunesse
- Je pense que dans l'univers
bien, surtout avec ces nouveaux
s-là qui arrivent.
Je pense qu'on est un petit peu
peut-être précurseurs, par
avec publicités. On va voirarri.
on ne le sait pas, comment...
L'univers des platr,
puis il faut rester au courant,
puis regarder ce qui se passe.
- Autant Netflix que Disney
un accès à des dizaines de payst
cibler très précisément
- Et je pense qu'à long terme,
n vrai défi pour
l'industrie. Et je n'ai pas
encore vu de pistee quel seraite
d'affaires d'une industrie
québécoise de la télé
dans 10 ans ou dans 20 anss ces-
là qui se sont ajoutés.
- Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-